this is a production of cornell
university
good afternoon everybody thank you for
joining us in the greenhouse session
and we wish we could have been together
in syracuse new york back in january but
at least we don't have to brave the snow
like we often do
this time of the year
so in our greenhouse session we're going
to have
three talks today
and we will have kendra hutchings talk
first about top bedding plants from the
cornell annual flower trials program
bill miller is going to talk about
stunning
bulb displays using a tractor-drawn bulb
planter and then i'll talk about coping
with rising greenhouse energy costs
just a few housekeeping things um so
um there will be a link to sign in in
the chat and we ask that everybody sign
in
this session does not qualify for
pesticide credits but it helps us track
who's attending
and then we also hope that you will sign
out so you'll get a link at the end
which will have you sign out and
there'll be a couple evaluation
questions that will help us
do a better job in the future do a good
job in the future and help bring
relevant programming to you
during my i have a couple minutes for
announcements here i wanted to share the
screen um and show a few resources
uh before we dive in um so one is is oh
i should introduce myself i'm neil metz
and i'm a professor at cornell
university and a greenhouse extension
specialist
um so all the people at cornell that
work in greenhouses both on campus and
and in the county-based cornell
cooperative extension offices
um kind of the clearinghouse for our
information is at greenhouse.cornell.edu
and you can find our website here with a
lot of information on crop management
greenhouse structures pests and diseases
and businesses so feel free to check out
that resource
another one that i want to point out is
for greenhouse vegetable growers we
maintain
what we call our controlled environment
agriculture or cea website
and that's at cea.cals.cornell.edu
and i can put these links in the chat
shortly
and then i'm sure kendra is going to
mention when she talks about the results
of the cornell annual trials program
[Music]
she has her own website
at
blogs.cornell.edu
trial gardens
so all kinds of resources
and then lastly i want to acknowledge
new york state flower industries
there are non-profit
organization in new york state that
represents
flower and and plant growers and
greenhouses
and retailers and associated businesses
and so they
they help us bring programming to
to greenhouse growers they help
represent our greenhouse industry
at um
in albany
and
they help us also to organize we have a
an annual floriculture field day
the date will still be
scheduled but typically at the end of
july or early august
where we show off the results of the
cornell annual trials
then i think that's all i had for
particular announcements
then let me introduce our first speaker
of the day
so our first speaker is going to be
kendra hutchins
kendra is a research support specialist
she is our trials manager for the
cornell annual trials program um and she
will be talking all about that
kendra
um thanks neil and thank you everyone
for being here
um i think some of you have probably
heard my uh my introduction before but i
do want to start by giving a little
background about chilean and our program
here at cornell for those of you who
aren't familiar with it um and i'll try
to keep that brief so we can get to the
um cultivars
so um just a quick review of what trials
are and why they're important um they
allow us to test new releases and
improve varieties they allow us to
compare cultivars and they allow us to
provide feedback to breeding companies
regarding plant performance in varying
geographical locations and the
participating companies will go on to
use this information to direct further
breeding or to provide information on
plant performance to retailers and
consumers in different locations
um before the
new cultivars ever even reach us they've
gone through
an extensive evaluation process already
they the breeders will select parents
they make hundreds of crosses and then
they evaluate thousands and thousands of
progeny looking for the perfect suite of
traits um that will contribute to a
successful cultivar so what kinds of
things are they looking at they're
looking at a variety of characteristics
such as the heat and drought tolerance
they'll look at disease resistance um
the size of the plant the habit
how well it branches what how vigorous
it is they'll look at foliage size and
color and the uniformity of plants
and then of course they're looking at
flowers so they'll look for clear and
pure colors that come in unique and
stable patterns they'll look at the
flower form and of course the size and
number they want to see how floriferous
these plants are
so despite the intensive selection
process plants that do well in a
breeding greenhouse might not do well in
um different field locations across the
us and that's where our trials come into
play
so at cornell we're a project of the
horticulture section of the school of
integrative life sciences and we're
hosted at the botanic gardens which
means that we're accessible to the
public and we can provide more exposure
for participating companies we get about
80 000 visitors per year and it's a
really wonderful thing to be able to
share our trials with the public
so our cultivars are new releases or
previously released cultivars that have
been improved or need further assessment
and our trials are garden performance
trials which means that we're going to
simulate consumer growing conditions we
treat our plants as a home gardener
would but we're very careful with our
watering and our feeding so we'll
irrigate fertilize and weed as needed
but we don't spend an inordinate an
inordinate amount of time fussing or
fruiting the plants
we don't treat for pests or diseases
except for deer and at the end of the
season we just want to provide a
realistic data to participate in
breeders and sometimes that means that
plants fail
we might have plants that have unhappy
plots that have unhappy plants in them
but this is all part of the process of
collecting data on plant performance
so our our beds are in full sun and in
ground we do some unofficial container
trialing and we typically trial between
100 to 200 cultivars
and this year our participating
companies include ameriseed ball floor
plant binary proven winner select one
centauri and syngenta and i should
clarify that was for this past year
so
after we plant all of our cultivars out
in the first week of june we start
evaluating them two to three weeks
afterwards and then we continue
evaluating them two weeks every two
weeks during the season we rate them on
a scale of zero to five for the
uniformity of the plot we want to make
sure that all of the plants within the
plot are pretty pretty similar
we'll look at the flowering impact of
the plant and the appearance of the
foliage and then we assign it an overall
landscape value and then at the end of
the season i calculate the all of the
scores um compile that into a report and
then submit it to the freedom companies
so i just wanted to make a quick note
about the weather we had this year um
like many people in in new york state we
we had a very very rainy season um in
june nearly half of our normal monthly
precipitation came down in two days and
then we had a
heavy rains also in july and august so
some cultivars did great and for others
this was a true test of of their
performance
so moving on to the top performers for
2021 our first um
top performer is cypress
graceful grasses pit prince tut from
proven winners
this is a sturdy upright plant and it
was a showstopper all season long its
unique architecture and compact habit
makes for a terrific accent plant in the
landscape or as a thriller in a pot
combination we've grown it in both sun
and shade and it has performed well in
both
solanostamine color blaze newly noir
from proven winners um i like to say
that this cultivar is quietly beautiful
it's not as loud and as showy as some of
the other cultivars in the series but
this has an impressive presence
and um it's got deep purpley black
foliage it grows several feet wide and
tall and creates an arresting block of
color
sullen osterman colorblaze albrighto
from proven winners was a top performer
and a field day favorite
um and while newly noir is quietly
beautiful albrighto is about as loud as
they come it's got very showy fringed
foliage and purple red and yellow and in
the landscape it grows quite large
providing an eye-catching glaze of color
for being a media shower from proven
winners this cultivar adds a touch of
whimsy to the garden it's much more
compact than common verbena but it
retains an airy architecture even while
putting out hundreds of lilac colored
blooms
this flowered virtually all season long
and attracted bees and butterflies all
summer
petunia supertunia mini vista hot pink
from proven winners
this petunia sports a profusion of
intensely pink flowers while the flowers
are small they're there in abundance and
create a carpet of color the plants are
vigorous and held up well to heavy rain
these perform well in the landscape but
also do well as a spilling element in
containers
sedum elecambiano spirit from the neri
um although this this sedum struggled a
bit towards the end of the season
because of our very rainy summer we were
really impressed with its overall
tenacity its vibrant flowers provided a
catchy contrast to serrated lime green
foliage lending a textural element to
our display gardens
petunia deco sorbet from syngenta
this one was a favorite among staff and
visitors alike the coral colored flowers
are are really nuanced with contrasting
veining leading to a subtly yellow
throat
the plant is prolific and vigorous it
also held up well to heavy rain bouncing
back quickly after getting battered it's
an excellent landscape plant but it's
versatile enough to be used in
containers too
salvia unplugged so blue from proven
winners another top performer and field
day favorite
this salvia has been on our top
performer list before and for good
reason it's another versatile plant
growing well in the landscape that can
also be used in pots for a thriller
element it's a medium-sized salvia that
has delicate flower spikes rising out of
compact foliage it bloomed heavily
throughout the season attracting a host
of pollinators
petunia surfinia sumo pink from suntory
this petunia has true power flower power
it's got large hot pink flowers that was
good heavy rain
um often while other petunias really
suffer it's a highly vigorous variety
and created mounds of color
petunia itsy magenta from syngenta
what these flowers lack in size they
make up for in numbers the petite
flowers carpet the ground creating an
impressive color display the foliage is
vigorous and well branched but with a
controlled habit and making it an
excellent choice for the landscape
moving on to our field day favorites
we have helium this some credible saturn
from proven winners
some of you may have seen some credible
yellow which was a top performer in our
trials last year it's incredible saturn
follows up on this introduction sporting
large yellow blooms with a red ring at
the center
both yellow and saturn are bush-like
inhabit
they flower continuously throughout the
season
the plants can get quite large making
them a great option in the backyard but
can also be grown to nice effect in
large pots
either way they attract pollinators all
summer long the sunflower patch was
positively humming this year
scoville sir diva white improved from
suntory
scavola typically do well in hot dry
summer so i honestly wasn't expecting
our scobola to do very well after the
very wet weather that we had for much of
the summer
sir diva white surpassed our
expectations though and we had an
impressive flower display from them for
our field day in july
tylotus joey apex
this was a surprise field day favorite
because by field day these were not
looking so hot um they're a native of
australia and truly need drier weather
to thrive but it's unusual appearance
redeemed it in a lot of people's eyes
and i tend to agree as its architecture
and bottle brush like flowers about a
unique textural element in the garden
this was a big hit with visitors and
children in particular seemed drawn to
them
we are going to be trialing these again
this year along with another thai lotus
from venery and i'm really looking
forward to see how seeing how they
perform and hopefully we'll have a drier
season
echinacea purpuria polynation mix apex
from venery
this sturdy fairly compact echinacea is
well branched and produced lots of large
flowers in a variety of colors that
attracted attracted pollinated
pollinators all summer long it bloomed
well into october providing late season
color
solon ostoman color blaze torchlight
from proven winners another top
performer and field day favorite
this is another stunning coleus in the
color blaze series torchlight features
fuchsia burgundy and maroon foliage in
dusky hughes this coleus makes a
statement in the garden adding a
dramatic flair it performed well in both
sun and shade
catheranthus suarez kawaii white
peppermint from suntory
this line of vinca from sun to worry has
very dense a very dense compact growth
habit it forms pom-poms of color on the
ground
the white are the flowers are petite but
perfuse covering the plant the bright
white flowers of white peppermint are
punctuated by a tiny dot of red at the
center and these contrasts contrast
nicely with its glossy deep green
foliage
this variety flowered constantly and
consistently throughout the season
tapering off a little bit in performance
towards the end due to very wet
conditions
lantana luscious marmalade from proven
winners
this lantana got a lot of compliments
because of its vibra vibrant orange pink
and yellow colored flowers it started
off a bit rangy in appearance and was
slow to grow at first but it did fill in
by the end of the season and the color
was spectacular i wouldn't necessarily
recommend this lantana for its habit but
for the color palette which is really
quite striking
new guinea impatiens hybrid
spectra orange from syngenta
the entire spectre line of new guinea
and patients performed really well for
us this year the flowers suffered in the
rain but repeatedly
spector orange inspector red had the
most flower power with the healthiest
foliage of the five every child and the
plants were just covered in flowers
so on to our notable mentions
the first is brackientha granvia gold
from suntory
this was a real powerhouse of a plant
until it finally succumbed to our
relentless wet weather it was incredibly
vigorous right out of the gate and
pumped out cheerful yellow flowers on
sturdy stems the foliage was lush and
bright and it performed well in the
ground as well as in mixed containers
towards the end of the season the
flowers started to rot and the plant
suffered from too much rain but i would
bet that in a normal year with less rain
we would it would have performed well
into late summer
evolvulus blew my mind extra large from
proven winters
i really love this plant for its
brilliant blue flowers we grew extra
large side by side with the original
blue my mind and can confirm that it is
indeed larger and more vigorous
proven winners says that the original
will give the best color show but we did
not see any diminishment in flower
return on the extra-large
however if you're growing a volvulus in
a pot extra large is definitely going to
be better in combos
my main excitement for this plant is the
true blue color which is hard to come by
portulaca grandiflora sundial series
from banari i was really impressed with
how floriferous this series was and how
quickly they bounced back after rain
individual flowers would get disfigured
by downpours but the next day brand new
blooms would replace the ones that had
been destroyed the white variety seemed
to suffer the most in this respect but
uh with the dead flowers detracting from
the overall appearance but for the most
part these plants were real troopers
they formed a nice mat and would do very
well in a landscape setting as ground
cover
dahlia city lights neon from select a
one
this was one of my personal favorites
this year the flowers are a deeply
saturated view of pink and they rise
above the foliage so they don't get lost
the plants are well branched compact and
vigorous
and impressively they had very little
powdery mildew despite the conditions
being perfect they attracted bees
butterflies and birds and are versatile
enough to be used in the landscape or in
containers
heliotropium augusta lavender from
proven winners is another favorite of
mine this plant has an old fashioned
feel reminding me of victorian gardens
it has an upright form but it's also
slightly recumbent so that its lilac
flowers drape gracefully across its
bright green foliage
it fills in empty spaces nicely and
works in a variety of color combinations
it bloomed consistently was easy to care
for and attracted bees and butterflies
and finally petunia color rush merlot
star improved from balfour plant
this vigorous petunia has a vibrant star
pattern that attracted the attention of
many visitors to the trials it has a
mounting habit and flowers that held up
to all but the most intense rain we had
this season
so those are the the cultivars that i
wanted to feature today
i'd like to acknowledge our trial
participants um the director of our
program bill miller our horticulturalist
melissa cox and our fabulous interns
danny del conte and michael carney who
did the majority of the work in the
gardens this year um if you're able to
please come and visit us in person we
are um open and accessible to the public
um
and you can also visit our website or
follow us on facebook um or instagram
and that's all i have for today if
anybody has any questions i'm happy to
answer them
thank you kendra that was great
um i don't see anything in chat yet but
if anyone has questions feel free to
speak up or to put them in chat
um i can start with one kendra i was
curious with the wet summer that you had
last year if there were a particular
species that performed really poorly in
the wet conditions
well actually yeah i mean the sedum did
not do well at all
they're used to dry conditions yeah and
i was really surprised actually that the
portulaca did as well as
as they did
um
but yeah so we had some james britania
that that kind of just melted away
um and there were a few other cultivars
too that really struggled but i i was
actually really impressed with how many
you know how many of the cultivars
really withstood the heavy rain because
it was pretty intense this year
i guess the importance of good drainage
in a garden bed it makes makes a big
difference okay
kendrick did you have to do any
irrigation at all with all the rain
even uh
because we do have drip there yeah
very very little i think right at the
beginning of the season we had to do
some irrigation but you know actually we
ended up spending more time
weeding and uh
you know take taking care of the things
that were growing too fast because of
the rains
so yeah we didn't have to do much
irrigating this year at all
hopefully next year we'll be a little
bit more moderate
average
average yeah
um kendra how did the trials look for
this this coming year
we have uh right now we have about 190
cultivars uh
yeah so
yeah we have a pretty a pretty full
slate so that's exciting we have um a
few new companies and um
yeah we're we're starting to gear up for
that
well i like you say uh everyone's
welcome to visit them at the
cornell botanic gardens welcome center
they're
super easy to find i know whenever i'm
walking through there i see people with
their phones out taking lots of pictures
so it's a great
spot
the most selfied spot in the uh gardens
the first year we did the trials so
that's exciting
that's great
um
okay i don't see
uh any particular questions at this
point uh maybe in a moment uh either
between kendra and myself we can paste a
link to more information about the the
annual trials too
then uh let me introduce our next
speaker
who is professor bill miller
professor
bill is
in horticulture in our school of plant
science at cornell
and he also oversees the flowerball
research program
so he's excited to talk to us about some
of the new technology they have to to
put in as many bulbs in the ground as
possible over a quick period of time
so uh the fact that i'm yawning don't
let that take away from my excitement
for the topic or my excitement for you
folks being here it's just
it's just that time of day so
since um since about 2017
we have been
trialing and working with this
tractor-drawn bulb planter
uh that that we that we receive from our
dutch colleagues and more generally
speaking we do research on flower bulb
forcing it in the greenhouse with the in
cooperation with the dutch
uh flower bulb exporters association
we've been doing this since 1998
and
our our single most famous thing has
been the infamous gin and paper whites
where
when you are growing paper white
daffodils and they get too tall
as they do here on the control on the
left
you can uh irrigate them with about six
percent uh four to six percent uh
ethanol and it doesn't matter whether
that's gin or vodka or rum or whiskey it
makes them nice and short and they last
just as long and they don't fall over so
that's been one of our very famous
things
so what we'd really like to become more
famous for are these uh
these masked bulb displays
and this is very commonly done uh in
europe and and the technology was
invented there and the idea
is to plant bulbs with a machine
uh in the fall
under turf grass under under existing
turf
so when they come up in the spring you
have this profusion of color
on the left you can see mixed daffodils
on the right you can see a close-up of
some crocus
these can basically be monocultures of
one kind of bulb or one color or they
can be crazy mixtures either way
and we'll that's what we'll be talking
about today
um
some of the advantages of this and and i
think i can show you before we before we
do that
um
let me
let me show you oh well the trouble is i
think i'm going to have to
have to uh
do that differently so here i'll just
i'll just show this there are videos you
can google uh cornell ball planter and
you can see videos there is a hopper
it's hooked up to the tractor with a
three-point hitch there's there's no
hydraulics there's nothing complicated
about it and there is a double-sided
plow shoe that goes into the ground
that lifts the turf on either side and
the bulbs drop down under the turf
and so with this you can the result is
something that looks like this if you
peel the turf back
and and with this machine you could
plant tens of thousands of bulbs
in
one hour it's a very rapid thing
um
we there's certainly uh uh
possibilities for this and this is what
we've been demonstrating over the last
five to six years
um
uh that the
use of this for landscapes for
municipal landscapes uh parks
uh uh property commercial properties and
so on um
the thing that's that's uh that's nice
about this when you when you put bulbs
into the grass
you are uh increasing the possibility
for pollinators especially if you have
uh bulbs like crocus where where they
make lots of pollen and the early
pollinators love crocus
so you can improve the biodiversity of
the landscape
and by delaying the mowing since it's
important for the bulbs to let their
leaves grow after flowering i think
everybody's familiar with the idea that
you should not cut leaves of of spring
flowering bulbs back until they turn
brown and die
uh by having those kinds of bulbs in a
turf grass situation it reduces the
number of mowings on the grass
and it reduces the grass mowing costs
and it reduces emissions from the
lawnmower and so on and so on
when this has been done in city uh
landscapes and we've worked quite
closely with the uh city of detroit on
this
uh they report back that that basically
this kind of technology allows them to
invest
what would otherwise be a labor budget
into flower bulbs themselves so you get
a greater visual impact
and they also
report reduced injury and reduced
workman's compensation claims
and an overall better attitude of
the workforce for bulb planting season
because it is not then
a bunch of
work on hands and knees planting bulbs
one at a time it's it's planting bulbs
hunt hundreds of bulbs per minute
uh and and fundamentally standing up and
walking around and maintaining the
machine and not doing this
by hand
so if again if you google cornell flower
bulb planter you will find lots of
videos that we have put up on this
and and again this is this is an example
of of what a
bulb's mixed would look like this is
quite a dense planting
and then uh in the springtime you get
things that look like this this is a
this is down on long island um a mixed
row of daffodils and tulips and then
tulips only in the front two rows
the particular machine that we have and
i can tell you that it costs about
nine thousand dollars
and it's obtainable from
bulb export companies in the netherlands
they they are not made in the u.s but
but a bulb company
uh who who would like to sell you bulbs
is very happy to also sell you a machine
and the one that we have is 18 inches
wide and it plants a randomly dropped
swath of bulbs as you saw a couple of
slides ago
and
uh by by driving very closely to the
previously planted swath you can just
build up wider and wider
uh beds in the turf so to speak
so this shot right here is is one such
thing it's five rows there's a row here
here here
uh i think here and here
so there are five rows so this is five
times a foot and a half so this is about
eight feet wide and you know 100 feet
long or whatever it is and in good turf
you can hardly tell that anything has
happened so it's really quite an
interesting machine
i'm having trouble hearing you oh that's
funny that's my watch talking to me
um
density is interesting uh
the the
discussion that you would have if you
were to get into this if if you were
going to do this on the side it's a
landscaping thing
is density and we have been doing
uh research looking at the numbers of
bulbs per square foot and the visual
impact
and in this slide here
uh
at the cursor at the bottom left is one
bulb per square foot and then three five
and seven in in the small blocks as you
go to the right and then the big blocks
in the left is uh
here here on the on on the right side is
one bulb per 10 square feet and this is
one bulb per 20 square feet so you can
see there there's there's sort of a
of once you get into about five bulbs
per square foot you really cannot see
anything else so we typically recommend
that that municipalities think about
five daffodils per square foot is is
about the maximum that they need
we have been doing research on
what is the acceptable
first
date of mowing
in the late spring which is a very key
question and i'll show you a bit of data
on that
uh because the the turf folks they might
be itching to get in and mow because
that's what they do they like to mow
their grass
but they we also need to allow the
leaves of the bulbs to stay on the
plants
from a from a dutch and european
perspective the companies that do this
over there are quite sophisticated and
they have really interesting marketing
pieces where they show the exact same
bed uh taken here's february march uh
april may and june um you know this the
same bed
shown throughout
the seasons
and by selecting species
you can have quite a lengthy flowering
time
certain things are very good for
butterflies pollinators and so on the
alliums and nectar sporedom are are
really excellent for pollinators
as you can see here so these these these
are large companies that that uh sell
bulbs and they they they send their
planters all over europe and put these
plantings in
um some of our initial plantings uh that
the machine is capable of doing a
certain amount of turning it doesn't
make tight radiuses but it certainly is
able to follow a contour like you see
here at the bios whale and then in the
spring
uh
things begin to emerge so this this
could this could even be this year but
this was a few years ago so we have
daffodils and crocus and they're
starting to come up through the snow a
little bit later on uh kiana doxa crocus
and other things starting to flower
uh the same bed a couple of a week later
two weeks later daffodils are in full
show um
daffodils start to senesce
and then uh alliums and camasia come on
so we have we have color in this bed
from
certainly the middle of march through
the middle of june in a typical year
and it and it's quite it's quite uh nice
and and certainly the the pollinators
love these these long grass areas that
aren't known
uh as as soon as the middle of april
comes around it's it's very good for
that the health and ecology of of the
uh landscape
um
more natural areas this is at the
cornell arboretum
and uh this is normally a fairly high
grass meadow that is not mowed at all
except for the very end of of the summer
really basically in the fall
and on on either side of this walking
path we planted alliums and nectar
scored them and you can see they're
starting to come up
uh and here's here the plantings on
either side
and you can see that this is a fairly
wild area and not well maintained but
the machine is able to
to by the virtue of how it works it can
get into
areas like this that are quite overgrown
um like a lot of farm implements that
are in the ground it has some difficulty
with large rocks but but you know any
kind of halfway decent field soil is
fine
i could also point out that this machine
works and i should have put a picture in
this machine works very well
for planting tulips in an outdoor cut
flower situation
or a in a garden center display
uh you pick kind of uh kind of a
situation
it can work very well in in bare
non-vegetated agricultural land
um and and a grower on long island has
bought such a machine the exact same
machine
to put in plantings for their
uh
their uh retail garden center and they
plant two to four hundred 000 bulbs
every fall on on soil in long island and
it works great
um
and so here it is a little bit later to
show this
um
[Music]
and and just examples of some of the
plantings that we've put in
i i can i can just say that there's a
lot of uh commentary on this
and and whether
whether you could get this going as a as
a group of folks who like cut flower
growers who might buy a machine and
share it or rent it out somehow uh that
is that is certainly a possibility
um
the challenge has been in the last
several years with with covid
uh getting getting communities to think
about these kinds of things but
in some of the plantings we've done in
ithaca uh it has turned out to be very
nice there's been a lot of positive
comment back to the city and i think the
city is understanding that there's value
in doing this sort of thing
um
this is all the same plot that i've been
showing and then quite late in june uh
the the very last uh
uh uh tulipa luciana starts flowering
and this is a very nice
uh perennializing species tulip so it's
doing very well and then what will
happen we will we will let this go and
and then start mowing uh in early july
now for mowing there's an educational
opportunity and of course cornell is
educational but if this was
at your garden center or if you would
partner with a municipality
or a botanical garden or or the local
town and village or whatever
um there are opportunities for education
and the thing here that this is not
bulbs necessarily
uh in this case but these are cornell
signs where they are actively not mowing
the grass
especially on very difficult slopes in
other areas so they just made these
signs tall grass small gas
and they talk about
you know natural landscapes and reduce
reduced emissions and so on and so on
um
this picture here
is is a result of some of the the very
first research we've been doing on
mowing date
and in this this picture what we have
are different uh different replicated
plots
and there are five of them in each panel
uh and this is daffodil teta tet
narcissus tatatete that little dwarf one
and this photograph was taken in the
third year after these plots had been
mowed
two
prior years
so these plots have had two years of
different
mowing dates
imposed on them
and so over here on the right these very
nice plots
of the up and down you can see the four
of them five july these were basically
mowed after all of the leaves had had
died back for all intents and purposes
and that would be after the fourth of
july
if you go over to the left 16 may um
when when these plots were mowed again
the two years prior so it happened twice
uh may 16th well if you think about may
16th
there are still very late daffodils
flowering and you can see there's about
every uh
10 to 12 days in between we mowed them
and and it turns out um
you can see that certainly the earliest
their mowed the fewer flowers we have uh
in subsequent years okay
and the trick that we're trying to
figure out is really what are those
dates
and and with
with crocus and with the teta tets that
we just looked at
and and probably with silla siberica
sometime about the first week of june um
we we believe that it's generally safe
to do the first mowing
on many of these in-grass bulbs
and
we think that's notable because that's
about a month earlier than
than most people typically would wait
which again would be about the first
week of july when thing when all the
leaves are totally yellow
so with this research um
we're seeing that there's really not a
big difference in flowers from from a
june 9th mowing to a july 7th mowing and
and this particular graph
had been after three
mowing seasons so that this is really
quite a long-term experiment that we're
looking at here
some of them we don't think it matters
very much crocus thomas
thomas indiana's ruby giant which is the
earliest one
uh
there's there's
really may 20 the end of may is is safe
to mow these
so we're we're identifying mowing dates
for different species um
over time in the research that we're
doing
so i've got just a couple of a couple of
minutes um and if there's any questions
i see the chat are there any questions
neil in the chat
right real quick and then if not i'll
show a few more pictures
um
steve asked
uh
can the bulb planter control plant
density and spacing oh yeah good point
thank you steve uh yes it can control
plant density uh in a in a crude way
there is a gate which you can open or
close to regulate the flow of bulge out
of the hopper and so so uh yes there is
a certain amount of control for that and
that depends on the bulb size and it
depends on whether it's a mixture or not
but we can certainly we can certainly
regulate that uh to to quite a large
extent
um we've done other uh demonstrations
installations uh
especially down on long island with with
nasa and suffolk counties they've been
quite involved in this
um
you can go a little bit over the top
with some of these displays this is at
the front gate of eisenhower park in
nassau county and
these were these were leftover bulbs
that we had so we really gave them a
nice show and it's fantastic people
people really love this stuff
um
ithaca is working on a one more minute
ithaca is working on a defined
funding mechanism for individuals and
business owners
to
formally contribute uh money uh into a
bulb budget
and because we've done a lot of
plantings in downtown ithaca and garden
clubs have gotten involved service
organizations have been giving small
grants for this and and so there's
there's some possibilities coming along
and again lots of nice things uh the the
bees the bees loving the crocus other
pollinator benefits and so on
so i'm i'm probably a little bit out of
time um
i i would be happy to
see if there are any other questions
you're right on time bill um there was a
question that came in on thoughts for
using the bulb planter for planting
garlic or onion sets
oh did steve reiner's ass
he did yes well if steve if steve would
get some uh
garlic cloves to us in the fall we
should try that but i i think it would
work just fine
um and i think it would work fine for
onion sets it it does not
uh it does not plant in rose it plants
in a swath in an 18-inch wide swath and
when when the bulbs drop down
they they bounce around randomly and
it's not the case that that bulbs that
the pointy side has to go up and the
roots go down the bulb takes care of all
of that itself
so it doesn't matter so so uh
planting
planting onion sets would be just like
planting a kiana doxa it would be fine
they wouldn't be precisely placed but
they would you know again we can adjust
the the general planting density quite
nicely with the machine
that's great thank you let me ask um oh
sis
someone asked about lily's daylilies or
other late season plantings oh good
question uh we have not tried lily's and
i i think lily's would be
problematic because
of of the the way the hopper works in
the belt that drives the bulbs up to the
gate
and then the bulbs have to kind of
squish through the gate
my my fear is that lilies might get
damaged um because they they don't have
that papery tunic that a tulip or a
daffodil
or a hyacinth does and and that those
scales would get broken off i that's
that's my fear
interestingly we have tried day lilies
and i think we tried hostas as
whether this machine could be used to
plant bare root perennials
um and and and direct direct planting of
bare roots into larger landscapes is a
totally legitimate thing to do
but the difficulty with this is that
is that with when bare roots are planted
if they are planted
significantly under the ground uh if if
they're planted two or three inches deep
if the crown of the bare root is under
the ground
uh they are very stunted in their growth
and emergence
and it's definitely the case that with
bare roots you the the crown needs to be
planted right on the soil surface so
that they they get that signal of light
and and they they root and they start
growing
um
so no i don't think this has a place
with bare roots unfortunately
okay thank you bill that was an
excellent presentation
um i'm fortunate that i live in ithaca
and get to see the benefit of all these
plantings when i drive to to work every
day in the spring so thank you
then i will continue on with our last
presentation of the session which is
coping with rising greenhouse energy
costs
and unfortunately we are we are here
again so the reason i'm going to talk
about this topic is we've noticed that
especially over the last uh 12 18 months
or so energy prices have gone up again
um
we hit kind of a uh a low in energy or
decrease in energy prices especially
that first spring of covid
when people were staying at home using
less energy
fuel prices went down
and now they've they've gone up so just
in the last 12 18 months instead of
paying two dollars per gallon for fuel
oil we're paying about three and a half
dollars per gallon for fuel oil
um i'm going to talk a little bit about
strategies for reducing energy use i'll
talk first about energy audits and
benchmarking and grants that are
available then i'll talk about energy
conservation which are things that you
can do
with the structure or the equipment that
you already have
and then energy efficiency which would
be upgrades to to equipment or to fuel
to further save energy
so we'll dive right in
and one of the things i like to think
about if you're looking at saving energy
in your operation
is this energy pyramid where it's most
cost effective to start at the bottom of
the pyramid
that's where your quickest cheapest
gains and energy use can be made and
then at the top of the period are are
these more expensive
components so the the cheapest things to
do are to analyze your energy use
whether that's yourself or whether
that's through getting a free business
energy audit that's available
through nyserda for example
to analyze how you're currently using
energy and see what changes can be made
then energy conservation then new
equipment that gets used with energy
efficiency
then time of use management so that
could be say upgraded controllers so
that your
heat or your lights are
are on
when needed and not on when not needed
and then finally once you've taken
advantage of all those existing energy
changes
that that would be the time to consider
renewable energy um to to then reduce
your energy bill because you're making
your own energy such as
solar or wind for example
um so just a little bit about energy
audits this provides an overview of your
current energy usage it typically um
through a formal procedure you'll you'll
have someone come and visit
they'll do a site visit
they'll look through utility bills
ideally they'll look at three years
worth of utility bills they'll also look
at specifics for your equipment like
what type of boiler you have for your
greenhouse or furnace that you have for
your greenhouse
then based on that information they're
going to estimate energy savings or
practice changes or equipment upgrades
and then they'll also give you a
framework for using that information so
they'll help you prioritize
what is the return on investment for
upgrades so you can see what what is
most cost effective
for your operation
here's an example of an energy audit
where uh there were some recommendations
that came in
um they have an estimated payback period
the installed cost and whether the
energy being saved is electricity or
whether it's its heating fuel so
installing a higher energy efficiency
lighting system depending on the type of
system you install could have a payback
of one to ten years
installing lighting controls
at a cost of five to eight thousand
dollars per controller would have a
payback of one to three years in this
case
um and then in terms of saving on
heating fuel installing an energy
curtain to to retain heat in the
greenhouse
would cost two to five dollars per
square foot and have a one to three year
payback
upgrading the the boiler the furnace to
a condensing heating system would have a
two to five year payback and then
upgrading the glazing material i think
this particular example was uh an
infrared
locking glazing material that helps to
track trap the
long wave radiation from the sun in the
greenhouse
a related
process is called energy benchmarking
and this is this is relatively new
there's a few different energy
benchmarks out on the market um the idea
with these is is that you track your
current energy use which would again
relate to using utility bills to track
the energy that you're using
um these what these benchmarks do is
that they allow you to um compare your
energy use to anonymous peers of similar
size and technology so so besides
entering your information you get to see
how
anonymous other people
are doing as well that can help you
realize okay i'm using a lot more energy
than other
greenhouse lettuce growers or other
greenhouse flower growers let me let me
dive in and see what we're doing
differently
and then this also gives you
that a framework for making
changes over time and by by tracking
energy use over time you can track
those those energy improvements that
you've made
um we have so so i'm part of this um
research group called glaze.org glaze
stands for greenhouse lighting and
systems engineering um we're currently
working with nyserda new york state
energy research and development
authority to offer an energy benchmark
for free to 80 greenhouses in new york
state
nyserda also has
a free energy audit program
so you can go to their their website
nyserda.newyork.gov
or you can google nyserda and
agriculture energy audit and find
information about enrolling there
i think they have a little bit of
information about the energy benchmark
program too but otherwise you can go to
glaze.org
to find information about the the
database and benchmark to all
so we're fortunate in new york to have
um nyserda as a strong supporter of
these
these
energy audit and benchmarking programs
in terms of money that you could get for
making energy efficiency
upgrades
i always recommend reaching out first to
your utility company oftentimes utility
companies will have incentives for
energy efficiency
so they they can give you money back
for the improvements that you make
and then
we also have the usda through the
natural resources conservation service
through the nrcs
there's a program that they have every
year that's called reap
renewable energy and energy efficiency
and what this program does
it actually provides 25 that should say
grant so you get
you get a quarter of the cost of energy
efficiency upgrades paid for um and then
they also have 75 percent loan
guarantees as well to help make sure
that you can get the uh the money if you
need a loan um to make those upgrades
um for the the nrcs grants i always
recommend that people check with their
county office first about the current
programs that are available um and the
the county office folks sometimes can
offer you support in terms of filling
out the application or getting the
information that you need
so then let me move on to these
energy conservation and energy
efficiency measures
i get this question a lot why does it
cost so much to heat a greenhouse and
it's a valid question
greenhouses unfortunately don't have the
same amount of insulation as our homes
because we're trying to let in as much
sunlight as possible so we typically
have glass or
plastic or polycarbonate
and that's made to be really good at
letting light through but it's not very
good at trapping heat
we can look at
the ability to to trap in heat as the
insulation value or the r value
and so
here a larger number is higher
and
one of the big things to to notice here
is that a two inch
foam board has about 10 times the
insulation value as a single layer of
plastic or a single layer of glass
and then six inch thick
fiberglass insulation has about 20 times
the insulated value so if you think
about heating a thousand square foot
house
it's going to cost 10 to 20 times more
to heat
that same square footage of a greenhouse
one of the one of the things that we can
adopt is using double layer either
plastic or polycarbonate
and that does improve the r value so
that that does improve the
reducing heat loss
in that case the expense is that it
reduces the the transmission of light
somewhat so a single layer of plastic or
glass let through about 90 percent of
the light a double layer of plastic or
glass will let through about 80 percent
of the light
so energy conservation steps are simple
actions that you can take to reduce your
energy with the structure and equipment
that you already have
um so these could be things like furnace
maintenance they could be
actually scheduling your crop so that
when you
open up your greenhouse and start
heating it that your that your
greenhouse is full
and not half empty
it could also relate to reducing the run
time of equipment so if there's
maybe lights that are on in the
headhouse of your greenhouse you could
have those on a sensor so that those
lights turn on only when there's
actually people working in that head
house for example
um one of the the most common energy
conservation measures that we recommend
is reducing air infiltration which
essentially means sealing the leaks in
your greenhouse
so any kind of leak is going to let the
warm air out of your greenhouse and let
the cold air in
and so that could relate to patching
holes in your your polyethylene plastic
that you have
sealing up other leaks actually weather
stripping doors
so if your door has a 1 8 inch gap under
the door
you can lose two dollars worth of heat
per hour so imagine that just putting
weather stripping on the door that's
going to have a return on investment of
like a day
then another measure that we recommend
is installing perimeter insulation um
this would have to be below the the
bench height because we want your crops
to get as much light as possible um but
below the bench height you could install
one to two inch foam board ideally that
would be sunk one to two
feet into the ground so that you don't
have incursion of those cold
temperatures up through the the
florentii or greenhouse
so these air infiltration methods can
save you five to fifteen percent of your
heating energy bill
uh then i want to move on to talking
about energy efficiency measures so
these are using less energy by upgrading
your equipment or switching to more
energy efficient equipment
so some of the equipment upgrades could
be replacing your old furnace with a
more efficient one replacing your your
lights with more efficient ones adding
energy curtains to retain heat um as
well as considering different fuel
sources so
if you you might have access to a more
cost effective
fuel source
so energy curtains
these are uh
retractable close-weaved curtains so
these are often made of an aluminum type
of material
they typically serve a dual purpose so
that you can get curtains that provide
say 50 shading
and you can use them in the hot summer
days when you want to to keep your
greenhouse cooler
and they work by deflecting some of the
sunlight away from the greenhouse at
that point
but then if you deploy these at
nighttime so we'll close them at sunset
they can reduce heat loss at night by 30
to 50 percent
and the nighttime is really when our
greenhouses lose the most heat because
we do get a fair bit of solar radiation
gain during the day
so
over all these curtains can save
sometimes
20 to 40 percent um they can reduce your
heat loss by 20 to 40 percent overall
the cost is about two to five dollars
per square foot so they typically have a
return on investment of about two to
three years
um you can even consider multiple
curtains which give you even better heat
retention and that works because you
have the curtains themselves
and their heat retention properties but
then if you deploy multiple curtains you
get a layer of air that acts as as an
insulative layer
this was a greenhouse that i happened to
visit in japan where energy costs are
about three times higher than they are
in new york
um and you'll notice that in this the
strawberry greenhouse they actually had
three layers of energy curtains um so
they could really reduce their their
heat loss during the night time
another energy efficiency measure would
be to look at um replacing old boilers
and furnaces with new condensing boilers
or heaters
and the reason that these help is is
older boilers that are not condensing
lose a lot of heat through water vapor
so when you when you burn a fuel source
when you burn a fossil fuel um a lot of
hot water vapor is created and that
water vapor is at 400 to 500 degrees
fahrenheit and typically it's just lost
through this the stack of the the
furnace
and so these condensing boilers what
they do is they add a heat exchanger
that recaptures a lot of the
heat from that high temperature water
so then if you if you feel the exhaust
not that i recommend it it should
actually be be
room temperature or warm not hot to the
touch because a lot of that heat has
been regained
so you can get boilers
and furnaces that have an energy
efficiency of 90 to 95 percent instead
of the older ones which would have 70 to
80 percent efficiency
then um i always like to show this chart
to look at different fuel sources
this this there's a table that's
available online that's put together by
john bartok who's a retired greenhouse
engineer from the university of
connecticut
and in the table you can plug in the
price
for different fuel sources and then it
calculates the cost per million btus
so then we can look at these fuel
sources in kind of an apples to apples
way
and natural gas is by and large our
cheapest fuel source so if you're
fortunate enough to be on natural gas
that would be the the cheapest way to
heat your greenhouse
in this scenario about fourteen dollars
per million btus of heat
and a lot of them are rural growers
unfortunately are on uh you either have
to get propane or fuel oil and so your
cost per million btus can be can be
twice as much
so biomass fuel sources like
cord wood or wood pellets could actually
save you a lot of money for your fuel
bill especially if your alternative is
propane or fuel oil
some of the considerations that you
should take into account if you're
looking at alternative fuels is they
make the most sense if you heat through
much of the winter
um so if you're only heating in like
march and april
um it may not make sense to to upgrade
equipment or change your fuel source
because you're you're
have too many years to see the return on
investment
you also want to consider using a
material that's available locally or
available inexpensively
it should be something that you can
source consistently from year to year
you do need to think about having enough
storage space on site like for the cord
wood
or for a wood pellet hopper you also
need to think about labor for material
handling
i visited some some large greenhouses
that switched to biomass heat um and
they essentially budgeted for one person
working full-time
um to handle the to either like prepare
the wood load hoppers um and dispose of
of ash
so think about ash disposal
and then um in the end this has to make
sense economically considering all of
the costs so the cost for a new furnace
the cost for labor the cost for space
the cost for the fuel source itself
and as i mentioned our
upgrades to heating systems make the
most sense if we're heating for
throughout the whole winter so our our
months where we have the largest number
of heating degree days
are december january and february
um and then
that
really goes down dramatically once we
start getting to the spring months
installing an integrated
control system or or a computer climate
control system can save five to fifteen
percent of your energy savings over
thermostat control
so kind of the low-tech way that we
control heating and venting decisions in
the greenhouse is with a thermostat and
often there's a separate thermostat for
the the furnace or boiler and a separate
thermostat for the vents and what we
find is that sometimes if their settings
are not set appropriately or if the
thermostat is not located in a area that
is representative of the the whole
greenhouse temperature sometimes we
get into this unwanted situation where
greenhouse is both heating and venting
at the same time which can lead to
wasted heat
so what an integrated controller does is
it makes
all of these decisions
and it
takes into account additional
information so if we're deciding to heat
a greenhouse
it's controlling the vents the heat
they typically also have an outdoor
weather station so they can
track how much solar radiation is coming
in and so your greenhouse might be
calling for heat but then the computer
system realizes that the sun has come
out and our greenhouse is going to heat
up quickly with solar radiation so that
the integrated control system could
decide to delay heating for example
these systems can also log data so that
if something goes wrong you can go back
over time and say oh what happened
two months ago which caused my crop to
really go downhill fast
um and the the last a few slides that i
want to spend relates to greenhouse
lighting
um and so one of the points is that
greenhouse lighting has significantly
improved over the last 25 years or so in
terms of its energy efficiency
the way that we measure the the energy
efficiency of lights
is their um light output which is the
number of photosynthetic photons that
they put out
per joule of electricity and then again
a higher number is a better number
so what we find is that our older high
pressure sodium fixtures
had a lower
light output per energy use
even then a newer high pressure sodium
fixtures so
if you haven't upgraded your high
pressure sodium lights in the last 10 or
20 years this definitely deserves a
second look so nowadays we have double
ended
bulbs the filament connects on both
sides of the bulb and they also have an
electronic ballast instead of a magnetic
ballast
and those offer already
something like 65 70 percent energy
savings over old high pressure sodium
lights
then the interesting thing to me is that
leds have been much talked about in
terms of energy efficiency
in 2014 the best leds were not any
better in energy efficiency than the
best high pressure sodium lights but
then since that time over the last eight
years we've made really dramatic
increases in energy use efficiency so by
2016 they were 40 percent better
now there's some leds that are even
almost 100 percent better than high
pressure sodium lights
so if you haven't looked at greenhouse
lighting for a while um it could deserve
a second look especially if you
have crops in your greenhouse
again in like december january february
when we have the least amount of
sunlight outdoors
i get this question from growers a lot
which is which leds are going to be
reliable which ones how do i find what
their specifications are how do i know
what manufacturers to look to
um and there's this really nice resource
that's called the dlc or the design
lights consortium
you can find them at designlights.org
they maintain a list that's called their
horticultural lighting qualified
products list
and what this list does is
they actually have to have their
fixtures certified to be on the list
that they meet a minimum energy
efficiency which means they're they're
at least a bit better than high pressure
sodium lights
they maintain their light output for 36
000 hours so we rate fixtures in terms
of what we call q90 which is the number
of hours until the light output
degrades to 90 of the original so
they're 10 dimmer at that point um and
and they need to last at least 36 000
hours
um then the driver lifetime needs to be
at least 50 000 hours and the fan life
time of at least 50 000 hours and the
manufacturer has to supply
at least a five year warranty
so you can find
postings at designlights.org you can
also contact me i'm happy to work
through those questions with the growers
in new york state and and help you make
your lighting decisions
um
and then it seems like all i'm doing
today is mentioning different websites
um
do feel free to contact me in person and
i'm happy to
um to walk you through the different
resources that are out there um this is
another research group that i'm part of
port lamp so lampstart stands for
lighting approaches to maximize profit
and they have lighting calculator tools
one of them is really slick in that it
takes into account your location in the
us so you can input your zip code and it
reads off of um
10-year weather data so we know how much
light you get on average
every day of the year
so you can input specific things related
to your greenhouse the percent of light
that enters your greenhouse the target
light level for your crop the type of
the energy efficiency of the light
fixture that you have
your price for electricity and then your
greenhouse area
and then this will calculate um
this is in dollars per acre the cost of
lighting your greenhouse
so very expensive in november december
january and february and much lower on
the other months
um so this is this is a really nice
resource if you're looking at say two
different lights you can plug in
information on the energy efficiency of
the different lighting fixtures and
calculate
what the potential energy savings would
be
oh i do want to mention um
adaptive lighting control so so once you
have the lights installed in your
greenhouse
uh then the question is how do you make
decisions about when the lights turn on
and off
um and um
of course the less technical ways to do
that are just to manually flip a switch
to turn the lights on and off when you
as the grower think that it's it's dark
outside and they need light other
growers will put them on timers
um
but the timers don't take into account
whether it's a sunny day or a cloudy day
um so the most energy efficient
uh practice is to use adaptive lighting
control
where um that that climate control
system um is sensing how much light you
get from the sun
and is
making decisions about when to turn
lights on based on how much sunlight
there is so if it's a sunny day
the lights may not turn on at all or if
it's a partially sunny day
the system knows to delay
when we turn the lights on until
the end of the day
we have a project from
new york state egg and market through
their specialty crop block grant to
install adaptive lighting control
systems and eight pilot greenhouses in
new york state
and what this program will do is we
provide the hardware and installation
to test the system and what we'd really
like is is for a grower to
test say one lighting zone or one small
section of their greenhouse
and then compare that to how
they typically make lighting decisions
in their greenhouse
so that we can compare how the system
works for them
if you're happy with the system and its
operation you get to keep the hardware
at the end of the 12 month period
and you can contact me for more
information
um with that oh yes this was my lab
right before christmas when we were
wearing ugly christmas sweaters and took
a took a photo in the greenhouse
so feel free to shoot me questions
anytime by email
and i can also look at the chat and see
if there's anything there as well
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu